some bugs in your code are very
straightforward
you try running it you get a syntax
error somewhere python tells you exactly
where and you fix it this is great it's
simple and it's satisfying
sometimes though things crash and the
error is just kind of impossible to
understand this happens a lot in machine
learning for a few reasons you're
working with these big weird data
structures you're using these big
complex libraries with a lot of moving
parts
and also you're doing a lot of gpu
computing and that in general is much
more difficult to debug
in keras there's the additional problem
that your models are often compiled
before execution which is great for
performance but it makes debugging extra
difficult as well
so this is going to be a video about
what to do when you run into one of
those nightmare bugs and you just have
no idea where to begin with fixing it
so to give you some intuitions for
the the most common things that go wrong
and cause these weird issues
um and show you kind of where to look
for the sources of bugs that you
encounter let's use this example script
so i'll show it to you here in two parts
first we do all our imports we load a
data set we create a tokenizer and we
tokenize the data set
next we convert our data sets to
tensorflow data sets so that's
tf.data.dataset
and that's so that we can run fit on
them and then we load our model from a
pre-trained checkpoint we compile it and
we fit it with those data sets so this
seems straightforward enough it's
similar to what we've done in the course
before but beware this is spooky code
and hides many dark and mysterious
secrets
so what happens when we run it
well
it's not great so we get this error
message
but you know what does it mean we tried
to train on our data but we got no
gradient
it's it's
pretty perplexing i mean how do we even
begin to debug not getting a gradient so
when the error doesn't immediately
suggest where the problem is
the best solution is often to walk
through things in sequence making sure
at each stage that the outputs look
right that everything looks okay at that
point
and of course that means the place to
start is always to check your data
so the best way to make sure that the
data you're giving the model is good is
to grab a batch from the tf data data
set that your model is training on and
that that's because it's right at the
end of the training the data pipeline
and so that means that your if if those
outputs are good you're guaranteed that
your data pipeline is working well
so we can do that by looping over the
data set for one iteration and then
breaking and that gives us a single
batch
so what do we get when we inspect that
batch
we'll see that we're not getting any
gradient because we're not passing
labels to keras
so our labels are in the batch but
they're a key in the input dictionary
and they're not a separate label as
keras expects so this is one of the most
common issues you'll encounter when
training transformers models with
tensorflow our models can all compute
compute loss internally but to use that
loss for training the labels need to be
passed in the input dictionary where the
model can see them
this internal loss is the last that we
use when we don't specify a loss and
when we call compile when we don't
specify a loss argument
so keras on the other hand usually
expects labels to be passed separately
from the input dictionary and not to be
visible to the model and lost
computations will usually fail if you
don't do that
so we need to choose one or the other
either we use the model's internal loss
and we keep the labels where they are
or we keep using keras losses but we
move the labels to the place keras
expects them
so for simplicity here let's fix this
issue by using the model's internal loss
and we do that by removing the loss
argument from the call to compile
so
what happens if we try training now so
we recompile with that we call model.fit
again
what happens
well it does run this time but now we
get a loss of nan
so that's not good none means not a
number and it's not a good loss to have
in general
in fact if we inspect our model now
we'll see that not only are all the
outputs nan
all the weights are non as well as well
as the laws
so once a single man creeps into your
computations it tends to spread because
it propagates from the loss back and
once it's in the loss it's in the
gradient it gets to the gradient and
then once it's in the gradient it
enters the weight updates and then all
your weight updates end up as nan as
well so nan just completely destroyed
our model here but where did it creep in
first
so to find out we need to go back to a
point before the model was destroyed we
need to re-initialize the model and look
at the outputs for the very first batch
and when we do that we see that the nand
first appears in the loss but only in
some samples
so you can see this in more detail in
the accompanying section of the course
notes i am moving fairly quickly here
but we find that if we look at the
labels the samples with a loss of nan
all have a label value of two so this
gives us a very strong clue if we check
the model with
model.config.numlabels we see that the
model thinks there's only two labels but
if we see a label value of two that
means there's at least three labels
because of where zero is a label as well
so we got a loss of nand because we had
an impossible label in our data set and
to fix that we need to go back and set
the model to expect the right number of
labels so we can set num labels equals
three when we initialize the model with
from pre-trained and now hopefully we
can avoid this issue
so now we think our data is good and our
model is good and so training should
work but if we try running model.fit we
well
i mean the loss we do get a loss it is a
number and it is going down but it's not
going down very quickly and if we keep
running this out we'll find that it
stalls at a fairly high loss value so
what's going on
well when things are mostly working but
training is slow or a bit odd that can
often be a good time to look at your
optimizer and your training hyper
parameters
and this is where i want to mention one
of the most common sources of issues
when you're working with keras
you can
name things like optimizers with strings
so cara supports that and it's very
convenient but if you do that
all of the options get silently set to
their default values
so we specified our optimizer as adam
but in the process we invisibly got the
default learning rate which is 1e minus
3 or 10 to the power of -3
so this learning rate is way too high
for training transformer models we
should go back and specify the learning
rate directly not using a string so good
values here are between 1 e minus 5 and
1 e minus 4 so let's split the
difference and pick five e minus five
so if you recompile with that you'll
find that training actually works at
last the loss goes down efficiently and
it converges to a lower value
so again i did go through this quite
quickly and i strongly recommend
checking out the course notes to see
this in more detail and to experiment
with the code yourself and see what you
know what the errors look like and how
you can approach them
um but i've given you i hope i've given
you here a quick summary of
the most common bugs and maybe the most
common debris approaches to dealing with
them so good luck and remember to take
plenty of breaks if your code is giving
you a hard time